sympathie verloren was war der
aussätzige zusätzlich kommen zu einem
neuen video heute machen wir leute ein
kleiner zulauf zur aber nicht eingewöhnt
anschluss über heute kein gewöhnliches
live video sondern wir machen uns die 20
auf vorlage selbst wenn wir werden heute
die fake app benutzen und gesichter von
youtube verändern dann versuchen über
die gesichter nicht zu machen
das ist schwierig wer die app kennt und
das sind wahrscheinlich im fall von
haiti ist ja schon ein bisschen länger
draußen weiß dass die ergebnisse echt
teilweise einfach zum schreien seinen
durst gesichter ich wirklich lachen aber
einfach alle anderen gewicht wieso nach
reinen out oder so und das ist einfach
lustig mit meinem größten vorbild auf
youtube an und meinem besten freund auf
videos und sympathisch lacht ja
bekannterweise nie und mein imbiss ist
alles erlaubt und sagt ihr in der liebe
und im bietet alle verlauf sebastian die
captains motor wie er lacht bitte
screenshots was an und verlinkt
daraufhin teilte die richtig echt aus
und vor allem halbwegs ist doch herrlich
normal aus okay leute war der punkt für
mich wenn du lachst punkt wäre ich sechs
punkte damit steht es 1 0 für mich und
für weitere lacher kommt immer ganz
anders aus
das junge pferd im video also wieder
einmal so aus alter mit 80 jahren noch
in der kette gerückt werden ok gerechten
1 1 steht bei unseren und einfach eins
zu eins auf diesen heutige space
vielleicht liegt es daran dass noch ein
bisschen weiter mit unserem zweiten
kleinen daten der selbstverständlich
niemand geringeres als mit der nummer
eins mit der nagelneuen doch nein ich
fahre kein android wir bringen wir doch
ab mal zu machen wir jetzt wieder
konstellation macht ist die fusion aus
dem wandel der lassen wenn ich aufhören
wäre dass er eine firma gegründet hat
und seine bücher damit verständlich
machen
der richtig christbaum 3 1 hatten die
haare rosa gefärbt wieder los
[Gelächter]
apa red
[Musik]
das ist so ein bei montech
weitergespielt werden
der junge der es geht mir auch
vorstellen genauso 12 bisschen kräftiger
sitze zu hause fest weil in meinem
herzen
manchmal sagen machen wir weiter mit der
person die in diesem gebäude in dem wir
uns gerade aufhalten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist echt schön das wird alles dafür
geben
luca wirklich leute meine nummer zwei
[Gelächter]
und finaler showdown heutigen folge
macht ist natürlich in der beschreibung
verlinkt ansonsten finde ich hier oben
zufällig seine sie von mir hier könnt
ihr mich abonnieren